Speaker 1: Failed former President Donald Trump,
who again wants to be president starting in
January of 2025, is reportedly planning to
bring back firing squads for the execution
of death penalty sentences and wants to televise
elements of those executions. Maybe not the most
gruesome part, but at least elements of it. This
is all part of Trump's, I guess, New Look 2024
campaign in which he's talking about executing
drug dealers who he falsely claims are responsible
for 500 deaths each a line he has often repeated
at rallies. There is a wild, wild Rolling Stone
article by as a win sub saying and Patrick Rice
Trump plans to bring back firing squads group
executions if he retakes the White House. And the
article explains how Donald Trump has been asking
more and more associates about this idea. Trump
is committed to expanding the use of the death
penalty, the article writes, and he wants to bring
back some banned methods of execution. He has,
even one source says, mused about televising
footage of executions, including showing condemned
prisoners in the final moments of their lives.
This is very deranged. It is extraordinarily
authoritarian, and we should all be genuinely
scared about it. The article continues. Trump has
talked about bringing back death by firing squad,
by hanging, and according to two of the sources,
possibly even by guillotine. He has also discussed
group executions, and he floated these ideas while
discussing planned campaign rhetoric and policy
desires, as well as his disdain for Biden's
approach to crime. Here is another wild element
to this. In at least one instance late last year,
Trump privately mused about possibly creating a
flashy government backed video ad campaign which
would accompany a federal revival of these
execution methods in the vision that Trump
has. The videos would have footage from the
new executions, if not from the exact moments
of death. The source told Rolling Stone. The
former president believes this would help put
the fear of God into violent criminals. He wanted
to do some of these things when he was in office,
but for whatever reasons, he didn't have the
chance. For whatever reason, Trump wasn't able to
bring back death by guillotine and then televise
the executions. We don't know why he just wasn't
able to do it. So this is really, really scary
and crazy. And we are all right to see this and
to cringe and to say, What the hell is this
about? This guy is sick. But there's another
more practical question I'm wondering about, Is
this going to get out the vote? Is there a desire
from your average Republican voter to have new
and more not new to revive the more brutal forms
of carrying out execution and death sentences
like the guillotine and firing squads? What about
group executions? You know, the the sort of funny
there's very little that's funny about this. Very,
very little. It's genuinely horrifying. The one
part that is funny is there's a little detail in
there that shows Trump's lack of understanding of
how anything works. When Trump talks about group
executions, we all know it takes so long to carry
out a death sentence. Between appeals and backlogs
and all of these different processes that take
place. The idea that it would even be logistically
possible to coordinate multiple federal executions
on the same day and do it as a group. Forget about
the morality of it. Forget about what it means
for the country. Forget about all the idea that
it would even be logistically possible to carry
that out. Just shows Trump's complete and total
lack of understanding of how anything works and
a complete lack of a connection to reality. But
he wants to do it. My question is, is there really
an appetite for this, even from Republican voters
who were willing to vote Trump? Do they want
this? I have a hard time believing that they do.